everyone this is steve weintraub with
collider and i am thrilled to be talking
to the i'm going to use this the
visionary filmmaker behind the shazam
franchise i'm a visionary can i say that
sure be a liar
um so listen man i i'm so happy for you
uh with how that the first film was such
a huge hit and that you got to make a
sequel but we're at comic-con and you
were literally just off the hall h stage
i think you just came right over so for
fans um
and the trailer just came online yes um
yeah my notifications were like blowing
up exactly when we were on the stage so
yeah it's out there now so how like what
is it like before you step on stage in
hall age as a filmmaker are you like
nervous backstage are you thinking about
your talking points like what is it like
for you yeah
i definitely am nervous you know i mean
because yeah it's just such a big thing
and i'm you know i'm a big introvert as
well so it's like this day is very
draining for me to just like be
outgoing and talking to people uh but
then it's just like yeah what are people
how are people going to react and but in
there it felt amazing you know with just
the
the crowd reactions and everything
so i'm excited so the trailer just
dropped i watched it uh it reveals a few
things that i i didn't realize shazam
was going to fight a dragon
yeah you know like i'm glad we can now
talk about this so shazam fights a
dragon in the movie he fights a lot of
things yeah i know i wanted him to put
even more wake up monsters and all kinds
of stuff and i was put it all in the
trailer because i just want people to
see it like look at how the cool stuff
we've been making but yeah the dragon is
is awesome it's so funny you say that
because some filmmakers i know talk
about how they want to keep things back
and other people i know are like listen
whatever gets people in the seats let's
do it yeah i'm more like that i mean
some things it's like
you want to keep some twists and turns
secret but you want to show cool visuals
and i think a lot of people also sort of
forget some of it or like they don't
know quite the context so i don't think
it like ruins the experience it's more
like just gets people excited where are
you actually in the edit uh of the movie
well now it's just finishing it up you
know like all the vfx and you know
recording the music with a proper
orchestra and everything but the movie
is pretty much like the you know cuts
locked and everything so it's just
finishing it up right so you're
literally just waiting on final vfx
shots yeah and that's the the marathon
it's like hour-long vfx reviews every
day because it's just like
takes forever and it's so much but it's
it's looking pretty cool that dragon one
of the things that people don't realize
though um are how close to the end a lot
of movies and tv shows are because of
vfx and how many
like all the vfx companies are being
worked it's insane just yeah just
getting people available to do the
effects is that because there's so many
movies coming out now it's like a whole
you know after pandemic and everything
it's just every movie's now full-on is
there one sequence that is really like
pushing the boundaries of vfx in terms
of were you nervous to put it in the
movie just because of what it was going
to rely on there's stuff with like
some of the powers of the sisters that
um
you see glimpses of it in this trailer
but we're still kind of tweaking and
figuring out exactly what it looks like
where it's uh
yeah it's hard to talk about without
being spoilery but it's it's a very big
power
when did you first know that warner
brothers wanted a sequel was it like
opening weekend that they called you
pretty much i mean it was yes
the first movie just came out and we
were already sort of having meetings
about well what's the sequel going to be
and trying to figure that out so
didn't feel like there was ever a point
of like oh is there going to be a sequel
or not you know there are many ways you
could go with the sequel how close did
it come to being like an another movie
versus like the story that you ended up
telling i mean we at first we sort of
looked at following the the comic book
closer the the sort of the new 52
version because there were new issues of
that but it felt like we wanted to do
something
more
in our world because the comic book sort
of goes way into sort of the sort of
fantasy lands and stuff like that
um but once we had that down it was sort
of you know we knew we wanted to do more
with the family because the family isn't
in the first movie that much they don't
even know about shazam's power so we
wanted to see them all together and just
up the stakes and just to do more of
everything can you reveal i don't know
if this is like if you want to or not so
if you don't want to i get it is it like
is the movie two hours is it two and a
half like how long is the film
uh i don't know if i'm allowed to say
that but it's like it's it's very
similar to the first movie let's say
that
i understand yeah um was this because uh
it's not like a three-hour movie no of
course not but what i'm saying is like
is there at the studio at the studio
level do they sort of whisper in your
ear would be great if it was two hours
no in fact i've actually been told by
the studio like we make movies not run
times so they that's sort of how they
feel about it it's mostly about you know
you test a movie and then if people feel
that
it could be shorter in places then you
look at that but uh no there's never any
mandate of it has to be like under two
hours or anything you've obviously
tested the movie um i've heard that
you've tested the movie i'm curious what
did you learn from those screenings that
actually impacted the finished film it
was mostly
actually tightening up in some places um
because we had there's a lot of stuff
going on with like monsters and
everything and we had some sequences
with that were really cool that had a
lot of monsters but it didn't really
involve the family
and so it felt like well you can
probably take that out because people
want to see
more of shazam and the family and even
though the monsters just
creating havoc havoc
in cities are cool too but yeah
i like in the trailer there's a joke
about fast and the furious yeah um is it
tough to put something like that in do
you have to get permission or is it sort
of like whatever we're talking about
movies no i think that was yeah
permission is not a problem i mean
everyone liked that and you know chris
morgan worked on this movie so you know
wait did he write that joke
i don't remember who wrote that joke if
it was henry or him but uh but it's
great i mean and it's two helen mirren
who was in the
franchise
listen i love um i love the tone of
shazam one of the things that i commend
you on with the first film is there's
really fun light-hearted jokes and then
there's some pretty dark stuff in it
yeah like with monsters and how much are
you able to do that again in the sequel
a lot like
i like
you know playing with the tone like that
of having yeah we have the fun stuff but
we also have some pretty dark and pretty
emotional stuff it's a pretty emotional
movie actually
um because i you know it's nice when a
movie is like
a full meal you know it's not just
focused on one thing
so rachel ziegler is in the movie from
west side story for people that might
not know her name and i wasn't sure what
kind of role she had in the film until i
saw the trailer and saw maybe she has
powers she does yeah i mean that's
in the film that is a bit of a twist but
it's a pretty early twist so you kind of
had to put it in trailers and stuff
because we're gonna see
you know it's hard to hide that in the
movie well if if her that's the thing
like for me if something's gonna happen
in like the first 20 minutes of a film
yeah it's not really a spoiler because
it's really early like it's not like
this is a third act reveal no it's not
so and yeah you we want to show her off
you know because she's great in this
movie she does some really cool stuff
i'm very do you uh just have to ask does
she sing
she does not this is the one movie where
she doesn't sing like yeah she's you
know she said snow white and west side
story and it's like oh maybe we
should have
had her sing
you know being the one she probably
won't sing in hunger games though
i don't know well actually
you never know there could be like an
acapella moment she's talking i'm sure
who knows um so obviously shazam and
black adam are on a collision course if
you will at some point they're gonna
meet up um
have you have you talked like how much
is that sort of a conversation that you
are a part of to discuss like where is
this ultimately going because there's no
way it's going to stop with shazam too
there hasn't really been a conversation
about that i know like
at the moment you know black adam is
sort of its thing and shazam is its
thing and then i
will see where it all
goes in the future but i haven't really
been a part of any conversations like
that making any movie is a challenge and
you're building the infrastructure on
how to make the movie like what's the
visual language of the film what is it
like behind the scenes how hard is it to
do certain vfx shots what did you learn
making the first film that really helped
you making the sequel
i mean it's a lot of
combination of a lot of things i mean
just smaller things that we had so many
problems with the light up bolts in the
first movie which we try to do
practically uh and then this one is like
let's not even bother because it kind of
turns into the effects anyway
so in this one we just you know you have
some interactive light you put on there
but then do it mostly with the effects
because it just it looks better i
actually like the bolts better in this
movie where
it is mostly cg rather than the first
one where it was mostly practical well
also the actors don't have to carry
batteries this way
well they still did because you have to
have some interactive light but it
didn't it wasn't as
sensitive and like it didn't break down
as much because it was like a simpler
design
uh obviously the first film ends with
the a lot of people getting powers and
in the trailer we can see that
they're sort of not breaking up but
everyone seems to be maybe using their
powers and doing their thing can you
sort of talk about like what the journey
is for
like the the family
yeah i mean in the movie billy
shazam you know he's trying to keep the
family together but they're
you know everyone's sort of doing their
own thing they haven't really learned
how to work together
uh and especially like freddy you know
he just wants yeah i'm gonna be a
superhero on my own like why do we have
to do everything together so the movie
is
sort of about them having to
learn to work together and be a
superhero team in the writing process
can you sort of talk about one again i
want to go commend you on i really love
the tone and how it's fun and funny and
a little dark like talk a little bit
about in the writing process how how you
find that line and you know what i mean
like keeping that tone because it's
tricky yeah i mean henry gaiden and and
chris morgan worked on the script i mean
they're the ones who do that i mean
they're great and then we play with it
on set as well
um just actors and and the whole thing
so it's
i don't know we just sort of do what
feels right and then of course always in
the edit there's some tweaking like oh
maybe we went a little too far here and
just tone it down
but it's a very collaborative process
what can you actually tease about the
villains and having helen mirren what do
you want to tell people about them
i mean they're so cool because they all
have such different powers
um and they're
they're very powerful i mean they're
gods
which is just really cool to see them
come to earth and
really mess things up and there's such a
good team together i i mean it's a dream
just working with like lucy lou helen
rachel segler i mean it's the the best
team ever how close did you come to
another title how did you end up with
the title that you have
i think that was
marketing or something because we didn't
really know we just like oh yeah it's
shazam too i guess but it's then someone
pitched like fury of the gods it's like
oh that sounds really cool i like that
title
um well you know sometimes like i've
spoken filmmakers and they have like 10
titles and they're debating which one
it's going to be yeah i mean like it's
no this one was easy because it's like i
think
i don't remember any other suggestions
really so it's just like yeah perfect
you don't just do shazam movies what are
you actually working on that you might
do as like a next project before you do
possibly another dc thing working on a
couple of things i mean my
goal
next is to do a smaller kind of horror
thriller sci-fi that area so we have a a
couple of projects
in the pipeline we'll see which one sort
of goes first
um but yeah i'm after two shazam movies
in a row i'm just like i just want to do
oh go back to horror for a second you
know also the thing that i've spoken to
a lot of filmmakers that have done these
big movies is you learn a lot of tricks
about vfx and things making these movies
that really help you when you're making
a lower budget movie you because you and
also sometimes the vfx companies want to
work with you because they know you'll
do another big movie well that's good to
know you know i've heard a lot of
stories yeah no i mean you learn so much
on every movie but but yeah you
definitely
learn things that are applicable and
like yeah what's the low budget version
of this or and it's just fun to play
with new technologies as well like we
did some of that you know led wall
screen thing which is all the rage right
now can i ask what like what sequences
did you use that for it was just a
couple of ones it was um
yeah they're in the trailer it's sort of
a rooftop thing and it was like in a in
a museum
sure and um that technology is crazy
it's really cool yeah i mean it just
helps with the light so much yeah it
looks natural yeah um no i love it and
you just get more stuff in camera even
though you do have to fix
a lot of things but you just you start
off from such a better place than with
blue screen uh my last thing for you
we're at comic con uh are you walking
the convention floor and if so what are
you looking to buy uh i already did
yesterday uh didn't actually buy
anything though i'd mostly just walked
around and looked at things
is there anything that like you geek out
over um yeah i mean i i was debating
this was a life and times of scrooge
mcduck sort of deluxe edition i'm a big
scrooge mcduck fan i was like ah
yeah
but i didn't buy it
because i already have
the old version
no i understand my thing is i've gotten
older is and i don't know if you're if
it's the same with you is that there's
so much that i want to get and then i
real i just i have to remind myself am i
really like you gotta have the space for
it yeah i'm at that point too but it's
like am i really gonna read it am i
really gonna you know am i buying it
just to buy it like what am i going to
move or get rid of to get this yeah you
know i think that that's the when you
get older it sucks
yes
these are first real problems anyway
listen man um i want to say
thank you so much for coming in i
sincerely cannot wait to see the movie
and hopefully and i'll say it on camera
when it's coming out maybe we can do a
collider screening oh absolutely los
angeles are you getting an imax release
or are you i
think so well hopefully we'll do it
hopefully we'll do it in imax on that
note i'm just going to say thank you
thank you for having me